all right Ben Affleck as a director
first Gone Baby Gone then the tan the
guy's two for two so now let's review
number three Argo
so Argo is the true story of a really
absurd situation in 1979 in Iran a bunch
of militia took over the American
Embassy and they took hostages but a few
Americans escaped without anyone knowing
and now it's a really time-sensitive
situation because these militia guys are
gonna find out that people escaped and
when they do they're going to go door to
door find them and kill them so we need
to get them out of there really fast and
there are no good ideas to do it every
situation ends in people dying and Ben
Affleck's character who's a real guy I
almost don't want to say character in
this movie the guy Ben Affleck plays in
this movie came up with this idea to
make a fake movie it's called Argo and
Argo is the biggest piece of [ __ ] you've
ever seen not Argo the movie that's in
theaters right now that that's a good
movie but Argo the fake movie in the
real movie Argo is terrible it looks
like the worst sci-fi ever made it's
like great be Star Trek Meets great be
Flash Gordon but they need credentials
it needs credibility so they need to put
this into a legit production and then
Affleck is going to go over to Iran to
location scout he's going to come back
with the Americans and they're gonna
pose as his crew it sounds bizarre and
unbelievable
only thing is it really happened and not
only is that premise entertaining enough
and the fact that it actually happened
is interesting enough but everyone in
this movie every human being who plays a
role in this movie is so good John
Goodman's awesome he plays the dude who
did the makeup for Planet of the Apes he
played a part putting this scheme
together and John Goodman kills in this
movie Ben Affleck really good in the
movie Ben Affleck can go either way he's
been terrible in movies he's been great
in movies luckily in Argo he's great
Bryan Cranston's in this movie Bryan
Cranston is in I think 90% of the movies
that exist or at least exist this year
and I'm pretty sure he is aware that
they're filming 50% of them the other
50% of the times people are like oh [ __ ]
Bryan Cranston's in his mailman's face
yelling at him being like I am the
danger film it and we'll put it in
something Bryan Cranston is great I
think Bryan Cranston might even be up
for a Best Supporting Actor nomination
for the Oscars I'd love to see that he's
one of the best actors working today
period the dude from homeland who was
really good and homelands gonna snipe
ranked Cranston in the Emmys that's fine
Cranston is gonna go for the Oscar Alan
Arkin is in this movie he plays the guy
who's the producer for this fake movie
his dudes 2 best he's like if I'm gonna
produce a fake movie it's gonna be a
fake head every scene this dude's in he
completely steals it I don't know if
he's in the movie enough to be nominated
for anything but if I ran the world he
would be so that's just my take on it
and I'm telling you the last half of
this movie I was biting my nails the
entire time the last half of our goat my
actually I bit my fingers down to the
knuckle these aren't my real fingers
anymore I had other fingers surgically
attached to these hands because I bit my
nails down to their intense [ __ ] but
it's not like you guns and rockets and
explosions or anything like that argo
proves that you can have nail-biting
intensity without a shot being fired
actually I think there are a couple
shots fired but point is that's the
point and it has really believable
dialogue between characters you know
people talk and they bicker back and
forth and they banter in the kind of
joke and sometimes it's funny in a dark
way that's important in a movie like
this just makes it more relevant and
real stacked onto the fact that this
actually happened Argo proves that Ben
Affleck is legitimately one of the best
directors of working today the dude is
three four three three shots three kills
that's not bad
everyone was praising Christopher Nolan
when he had that average so you know
what Affleck I salute you I mean there
are some shots in this movie you know
where the ambient sound goes down
slow-mo the dramas kicking up you're
just watching it you're like Affleck
don't get me wrong you were the bomb and
phantoms yo you've officially gone up
quite a few pegs just now Argo is a
flicks best movie so far in my opinion
and Argo is awesome tacular
I would not be surprised if Argo is up
for Best Picture for the Oscars and Ben
Affleck was up for Best Director for the
Oscars if one of those doesn't happen
I'll be surprised if neither happens
I'll be shocked or so what do you think
of Ben Affleck as a director I mean
actor directed the entire Affleck
picture what do you think of the dude
whatever you think comment below let me
know and as always if you liked what
you've seen here and you want to see
more click right here to see more